good morning obviously we had a great
jobs report
this morning unemployment down below
eight percent
and uh the economy continues to be
robust in its v-shaped recovery and
unfortunately uh that's not what
everybody's focused on this morning
as all of you know the
the president the first lady tested
positive
for covet 19. they remain in good
spirits
the president does have mild symptoms
and as
as we look to try to
make sure that not only his health and
safety and welfare is good
we continue to look at that for all of
the american people
he he continues to be not only in good
spirits but very energetic
we've talked a number of times this
morning i got
the five or six things that he had
tasked me to do like i do every single
morning
and he
is certainly wanting to make sure that
we stay engaged i think
the other thing that is is critically
important
the the doctors continue to monitor
both his health and the health of the
first lady
we'll continue to do that they'll
they'll be glad to provide some
some updates later today
as as we look at this but i think the
the the great thing about this president
is
is not only is he staying committed to
to working very hard on behalf of the
american people
his first question to me this morning
was is
how how's the economy doing how are the
stimulus talks
going on capitol hill a number of us
in the core team of the white house
continue to get tested on a daily basis
like we are
like we have been and as we look to that
we are very excited about making sure
that not only that the health and safety
of the president the first lady is
addressed
but certainly that we we address this
this battle together as a nation
together
and the american people can rest assured
that
we have a president that is
not only on the job will remain on the
job and
i'm optimistic that he'll have a very
quick and speedy recovery mark how are
you how would you describe his symptoms
and
is he taking hydroxychloride well i'm
not going to get into any particular
treatment that he may or may not have he
has mild symptoms
as we we look at that the the doctor
will continue to
provide expertise
in the residence he's in the residence
now
and in in true fashion he's probably
critiquing the way that i'm
answering these questions and
i can tell you that a number of us
will be reporting back to him
on on the the task at hand what day
in time would you just clear this up
what day and time did you find out that
hope hicks
had tested positive and did you sit on
it until after the president
went out to his fundraiser in new jersey
actually
as as we look at this i'm not going to
get into the tick tock i
can tell you in terms of hope hope hicks
we
discovered that right as
the marine one was taking off yesterday
we actually
pulled some of the people that had been
traveling in close contact
the reason why it was reported out and
just frankly is that we had already
started the contact tracing just prior
to that
event as you know last night even in
in the early hours of this morning the
minute we got a confirmatory test on the
president
we felt like it was important to get the
news out there at that time and so
that's why we sent out the the tweet
late uh late uh or actually early this
morning
[Music]
that's regularly on the president you're
gonna ask staff members to take
advantage of yeah
why aren't you wearing a mask right now
yeah so i've
obviously been tested we're hopefully
more than six feet away
and if if there's any any concern there
from a guidance standpoint
we have protocols in place and we you
know when
when when when early on early on
when we first started to tackle the
the covet 19 battle we actually did two
different things
in in the white house a number of
contingencies
as we looked at not only additional
testing but
but certainly uh uh mitigating the risk
for
for social distances in in private
meetings and
and the like but i think it goes to the
broader question is is even with
a lot of the mitigating factors jim what
you what you have is
is a virus that is contagious that that
certainly
continues to be regardless of whatever
protocol we have
that that it has the ability to affect
everybody as you know the president
we keep a a pretty wide circle all of
you that have interacted with him know
that
and so even with that wide circle around
the president we
we find that he's having to deal with
this like
so many millions of other americans and
people around the world have had
to do i can tell you i i can tell you
that what we're doing
is focusing on the therapeutics the
vaccines continuing to do that
and that doesn't change
[Music]
really quickly the officials who were on
the flight with the president on
wednesday including kushner
scovino i think stephen miller was there
are they all quarantining have they been
tested
we've tested all of our core staff and i
can tell you that
you know mr mr kushner mr scovino myself
a number of of us have been tested
have come back with with negative
results and yet
at the same time i fully expect that as
this virus continues to go on
other people in the white house will
certainly
have a positive test result and
we've got the mitigation plan in place
to make sure that
the government not only continues to to
move forward but the the work of the
american people
continues to work for uh move forward
and so even as uh
as recent as is this morning at a little
after eight o'clock the president was
giving me a number of things to
to make sure that i get done and i'm
sure that i will actually
have those do
outs have to be back to him later today
i've got i've got a wrap
mainly i'm not going to ask
so i wanted to come out and give an
update to all of you
is so that show the courtesy of giving
an update
we'll have future updates i'll be glad
to do that but any other specifics at
this point would be not